I think what we're looking at is Wanda
Maximoff searching alternate realities
for a reality where she and vision are
happy together throughout the Marvel
multiverse envision is of course I'll
prop used to torture Wanda by Agatha
Wanda vision reverse house of M want to
create a vision what the hell is going
on trailer did so much I don't care I
loved it so much and our hype level like
went through the roof suddenly when we
saw that so we're gonna talk a lot about
what's gonna happen in that show and
what it means for the mick you which is
what apparently did we found out it's
called I'm pulled Melina and with me to
go rogue is Eric boss I am back babies
kids that are watching Tommy Bechdel
hello folks so happy to be here thank
you so much for having me
they did just introduce a sarcasm font I
don't know if you if you've heard that
closed captioning said it was guys I
don't actually care about you guys I
want to know about Wanda vision yeah
okay so as you guys know we got a Disney
Plus commercial during the Super Bowl
and it showed footage from the upcoming
entire Marvel lineup for Disney Plus
Falcon on Winter Soldier a shot of Loki
which we made an eight-minute video yeah
and then really interesting footage from
Wanda vision so it immediately got our
minds racing Eric did a really good
breakdown of some options of it so
definitely watch that video but I want
to do a deep dive on what we think this
show is gonna be about and what its
implications are for real okay um I'll
jump on this first I after doing some
thinking about after releasing the
breakdown I'm thinking what we're
looking at in this trailer is Marvel's
depiction of how the multiverse is gonna
look in the MCU phase four so I think
what we're looking at is Wanda Maximoff
search
alternate realities for a reality where
she and vision are happy together
throughout the Marvel multiverse and so
after the events of Avengers endgame
visions dead and maybe after the time
heist has occurred she's talked to some
of the other Avengers and they're like
well there was a thing that happened
where Loki took the tesseract and
disappeared and presumably there's some
hypothetical timeline where he's still
alive and she's like hmm maybe like I
can access my telepathic powers to visit
or project astrally project myself into
some of these alternate realities but
because she doesn't know where powers
yet it's pretty chaotic she just goes
off her own reference base to like
things like TV shows
so she's chaotically jumping around into
these different realities where one is
like a Dick Van Dyke Show I Love Lucy
black-and-white reality one is where
she's with you know her husband and
they're raising twins and it's kind of
like a full house kind of thing and then
as everyone is in cheer yeah earns here
or cheers I think both could be possible
everybody knows your cheer I think like
in this teaser showed us different
sitcoms but it wouldn't surprise me if
really in these episodes we're gonna see
other genres of TV shows like Law &
Order a criminal procedural we might see
yeah an action movie type thing or it's
just like a Marvel Universe but like
like everyone is constantly a super
absolutely watch it watch it I think and
then maybe we'll get to one where it's
like horror or a musical or something I
had the way like some TV shows will do
musical episodes or please a musical and
in this case it's Wanda Maximoff using
her magical powers to project herself
astrally to these places her
consciousness is visiting this reality
she's not sure what it is but then it
jumps to another one it jumps to another
one it's chaotic but it's it's Marvel's
first depiction of how there are
alternate parallel realities and how
they can adopt these other genres in the
MCU and it's all part of this Canon okay
I like where you're going Aaron but I
feel like you know I have some points of
clarification I wanna get so you so you
I think if I'm correct you're saying
alternate realities in some scenarios
look like TV shows yes there's a black
and white alternate reality that's in a
Pleasantville style 1950s yes okay so
some of those alternate realities you
also took something know about she's
accessing her reference base and he
shows that she's been aware of like the
Brady Bunch or whatever what do you mean
how does that hurt her accessing that in
her head effect which realities exist
her reading them maybe that's the
question right like are these
multiverses do they exists outside of
her mind or is she so powerful that just
by thinking of a hypothetical she can
manifest and create it which sounds like
a pretty extreme power but then you
realize that's right and it's in
anything that he thinks can become a
reality but I think what they'll do is
maybe we won't stay in these realities
but the whole idea is for Disney and
Marvel Studios to introduce a kind of a
road map for us to look at how within
the MCU
there can be these alternate genres with
the idea of maybe in the future adopting
some of these genres and maybe by the
end yeah I would imagine by the end the
journey that one of Maxima is gonna go
on is realizing that maybe she doesn't
need vision to be happy that she visits
these other realities and realize that
there's other problems with them like in
a twilight episode what you think you
need it's not really what you deserve or
what you need it to move forward in life
so by the end she moves on from it but
maybe one maybe just in one episode
there's like a post-credits scene that
doesn't get resolved where she visits a
horror reality and there's just some
kind of link in that horror reality
where it's like the psychiatric hospital
where the kids in the New Mutants so it
ties in the New Mutants because we know
that like Marvel made the decision to go
ahead and release New Mutants and they
moved up want a vision to all come out
in the same year so it wouldn't surprise
me if there's going to end up being a
link between those two that that's
interesting Eric you get a Rogi but
actually you I think it sounds really
crazy your idea it's pushing the fringe
first well and it's definitely like why
would Marvel do this thing where they
have the successful reality already and
they've already shown that it can it can
withstand thor ragnarok as much so gonna
have kept America Winter Soldier right
it can it already has kind of a blend of
sure yeah but
what about into the spider-verse when
they actually show you different
realities that have like pig versions of
people in serenity and and more reality
so that worked really well for people so
Marvel could just be going to that yeah
because it's more real than when you
think another road all right and there's
there's places I can go with this just
so let me let me chew on it some more I
bet I can make this any more rope yes
all right
Tommy oh wow my turning let's hold off
on you for okay
that got me thinking a little bit but I
was I was thinking of maybe it's like
based off of like Marvel Studios
adopting the House of M from the comics
absolutely this has been the thing that
we needs that oh yeah ever since we
heard about like Scarlet Witch and stuff
we're like okay is this gonna happen and
if you guys don't know the House of M
storyline it's pretty much what happens
is scarlet witch's broken mind it resets
reality over and over again and then in
one of these realities she has two
mutant children mm-hmm weekend on speed
and then eventually it ends up with her
deciding no more mutants and poof
everyone's gone Aurel most of the
mutants are gone so I'm thinking maybe
she tries to resurrect visions broken or
dead robot mind by injecting or
inserting these wishful thoughts of
having these kids and then she resets
reality and she actually has the mutant
children and this could possibly set it
up for like I don't know young Avengers
and then also yeah bring mutants into
them too yes yeah so Eric and I have had
a conversation about this before and I'm
gonna pose this question to you so the
famous end of that the House of M that
main part of the storyline is the part
where she goes no more mutants what does
she say instead that creates more
mutants
let there be mutants I love that cool
like she refers to her own kids as
mutants what do we call these
just Marvel's version they're just like
freaks they call them freaks every kind
freak man welcome to the freakshow yeah
the exo so House of M storyline is going
to happen does that also mean that we
have to take down
Wanda honestly I think that that's gonna
be a hefty one maybe her mutant children
will sort of ground her a little bit
give her some some purpose well in the
House of M losing those children is what
drives our insane what if you lose but
no but my my theory is that it's like
reverse House of them you know what I
mean yeah creating the mutants and it's
like it's bringing them as though they
already existed and I'm see you and then
it's gonna be giving her finally be sane
if you have kids it fixes at home if
it's not working out I don't see the
kids but for a while things got better
because you don't look at them when you
throw them in there anymore Angelica
that is a Rogge because of course I
House of M is gonna happen in some way
or another because I'm so certain that
it's gonna happen you don't get any more
than one road but not bad Tommy hold on
you for a bit Eric second theory okay
well if Tommy's believing me I could do
this if you believe okay my theory
turn off your lights pitch a tent flick
on your flashlights cuz we're goin
supernatural I'm pitching the temptation
is going supernatural on this one so
after the events of endgame you know the
world has been saved the galaxy has been
saved but there is fallout we have lost
people in this in this war
including the love of Wanda's life
vision so she's lost you know
she's going out into the world seeking
answers for all of the the crisis that
she had and she she discovers the
presence of this older witch-like
character named Agatha in the comics who
was a mentor character to Scarlet Witch
no Agatha has been in hiding because of
her supernatural powers has cause you
know negative attention from law
enforcement wherever she is so she's
been hiding up and like I'm gonna say
like a cabin in the woods situation
where her only exposure to the outside
world is television so she's just taking
in decade after decade the evolution of
sitcoms dramas reality TV news
everything intelligence of her brain
which is already you know this massive
psychic power is now infested with
television themes so this is Agatha
this is Agatha Wanda finds Agatha and
Agatha does take Wanda under her wing as
a mentee mentor situation and she begins
to try and teach her how how she can use
all of her powers fully use the powers
who are full extent however at a certain
point in this training Wanda starts to
realize that Agatha is not a good person
the reason I guess I was hiding is
because she's done a lot of bad things
and is evil so they have a fight and
that fight causes a major event to
happen which draws the attention of the
other characters that we see in the IMDB
which is FBI agent Jimmy woohoo played
by Randall Park theoretical physicist
Darcy Lewis played by kat dennings and
then we have a grown version of Monica
Rambeau
from Captain Marvel so those three are
in pursuit of both Scarlet Witch and
Agatha at this point and it comes
together in this big battle and in the
middle of the battle Agatha snaps them
into a psychic prison of her own design
that takes on various TV themes and ads
and in each episode we're gonna see you
know first week at the Dick Van Dyke
theme and it's this cast of sitcom
characters you've Rendell pardon you all
these people have something in common
they're funny in real life
Kathryn Hofstra very funny metal Park
very funny cat dennings was on a sitcom
for like six years very funny so we they
are playing sitcom characters that don't
realize they're trapped in a prison and
as soon as the facade starts to crack
snaps them into another reality
is another TV show so each episode they
come closer and closer to realizing
what's really going on envision is of
course
a prop used to torture Wanda by Agatha
because she has an especially large
grievance against her so just a
psychological echo of vision is what's
in there yes there's so many things that
are happening here I mean at the end
there those Truman Show vibes right
we're like they're not realizing that
they're on a show but then also these
are gonna date me but there's a stay
tooned was a movie where he'll actually
looked like a black TV channels yeah
yeah but they keep changing TV realities
yeah they're all like different parts of
hell yes and that movie is really fun
and then also it reminds me of dream on
Jo where it's like someone who was
raised on TV because his parents fought
a lot is now hosting rogue theory he
everything is in the is contextualized
within TV realities so that's kind of
like her situation and the last thing
you just made me think of is kind of
almost like the shadow king relationship
in Legion in Legion which is kind of
this like more powerful beam that is
secretly like so freaking evil yeah and
then it's just like right there like oh
I can help you access your powers but
it's actually like I don't know maybe
I'm gonna steal your powers yeah yeah
it's also very dark and very creepy yeah
I think she wants to like I think
Agatha's motivation would be she sees
Scarlet Witch as a person she could turn
into a she could weaponize and get her
revenge for having to be in hiding
she is so powerful so yeah yeah that's
amazing Tommy oh that's amazing a
quarter Rogi yeah the best theory you've
had yet actually and then you can add on
guys I'm all about these give them back
to me in a tweet please okay Wanda
vision introduces the multiverse to the
MCU which looks like universes we have
seen before
that are TV channels I guess I said it
with an underline but it was a desert
well the problem is you kept looking to
Tommy for approval and I'll never right
now I'm gonna shock the world with my
tweet okay okay Wanda vision reverse
House of M Wanda create some units love
it yeah exactly
and then the W would be for Wanda Tommy
buddy okay so mine is Wanda Agatha
handshake emoji 100% that which no it's
not right me it's just a popular meme I
just a good my latest you know how they
have the thing will be like two things
handshake emoji what do they both have
in common being a represent that way
and I love that it makes you think it
makes you picture an image tweet section
Tommy stick with the white man wraps the
newscaster I just call them wraps I'm a
little more woke than you though we're
actually gonna get even further down
this car which diri line because this
auction actually surprisingly a number
of these things could happen but maybe
all three of them I bet there's elements
of everything but there's even more that
I know you guys were talking about where
you could really take off and get insane
so we're gonna do that after we just
talked about for a quick second just
some cool stuff that we're doing at new
rock stars and specifically I just want
to talk to you guys about discord we
have this if you guys you guys know what
a discord is everybody I don't know if
Tommy knows I noticed I just scored all
the time I just
friends in discord with my family I
escorted this morning three times
well those set now by context I'm
disgusted with what you do with your
family yeah yeah whatever I'm a G do you
not know what this Court is no okay
that's fine a discord is a place where
we get to chat with our fans and no you
said with our fence friends yeah with
our France
it's fans are patrons of a certain level
you get to go in there and we talk about
everywhere in there all the time we talk
about all the nerd news that shows up
during the day
we're just reflecting on in there what
else we do you're in there alone yeah we
have like ultimate threads that like are
we create some moderators who are in
there and know more about it than we do
have created like threats on Witcher and
on Watchmen and it's got like this
simple layout so like this isn't an ad
for discord it's just like it's become a
go-to for I think those of us behind the
scenes here at new rockstars to just
give our first gut reactions to things
and to like check in with our our guys
in the chair or our inner circle be like
how should we feel about this and we
also you use them for help sometimes
yeah it's like a graphic we're having
trouble deciphering you know those
people are obsessive fans yeah we don't
want to scourge people from like
tweeting at us or commenting underneath
our videos but really I feel like our
discord chat is where the conversation
for any rockstars has been happening so
but like the way you access that is
becoming a patron and it's like our
lower tier patronage if you can afford
to help us out just a little bit every
month this is a way that you can get
rewarded for that by by joining this
conversation and really this is a
conversation that leads directly to the
videos that you see on the channel yeah
like crazy on cheer and I mean Tommy
I love discord I couldna said it better
myself thank you for playing along with
that ridiculous farce that I don't know
what it is obviously there was a
teachable moment for our stupid fans
that don't know what it is so they would
the stupid ones will be smart like the
smart ones oh and Tommy you don't have a
computer right I legally can't have a
that's right I do have a tablet one of
those kids dinosaur tablets it just has
like Amazon PBS and Nick jr. on it so I
can push those three buttons and discord
discord okay so okay we've laid out what
we think might happen in the wand
division series and how it's probably
gonna fit into the MCU but now I want to
take those same theories and go a little
more okay so well let me establish some
rules before you say anything I want you
to get insanely specific with what you
think is gonna happen and I want you to
take some risks okay okay all right now
does anyone want to go first I want
maybe Eric all right because I felt a
little bad in my first theory even
though I did get the most rogue ease for
it I applied that vision was just used
as a pawn and that's my boy fizz okay
that's a guy that's Paul Bettany it's a
man who means a lot to me Master and
Commander a beautiful mind other films
he's been and so in my mind vision is in
this version my rogue is did his soul is
trapped in hell okay where he's being
kept prisoner by Mephisto so this is
where it gets real supernatural that
character of Agatha I mentioned before
is in this version as well but she is a
mentor and this time she's going to help
Scarlet Witch gain access to the portal
to get to Hell where we are gonna meet
all sorts of other supernatural
creatures this implies there could be
vampires I don't know heard of a man
named blade I've heard a little maybe we
have the existence of vampires the
existence of blade so I think that my is
that my rogue theory here is that those
TV channels are all different layers of
hell that Wanda is traveling through to
get her beloved visions soul back I
would love to see Marvel hell because we
know Doctor Strange the multiverse of
madness kind of looks like it won't go
to hell because they want the movie to
release in China but Disney Plus isn't
gonna air in China anyway so you can go
all the way derrickson was very
complimentary of the wand of
tensho and we know that his yeah we
think trouble with doctor or doctor
strange to and multiverses madness was
that they wouldn't use demonic things
wouldn't let them go to hell
and now well let's talk about that for a
second and marvels version of hell is
something that does not sound like
disney mmm-hmm but why do we need to see
marbles version of hell I just think
that did it allows us to explore more
Marvel properties like it explains the
involvement of you know like why would
vampires exist in a Marvel Cinematic
Universe we have all these super heroes
and super villains do we need
supernatural like if we have hell and
demons and the demons are nefarious
they're not like you know kind of
antihero demons if they're just evil
demons that type of mythology has been
around for thousands of years in the
world it's things that globally we can
relate to right like it makes me think
of like Justice League dark or something
or the Constantine character where they
you know obviously Superman and Batman
and whatnot should not be really
relating to demons or whatever but the
universe is big enough where they can
still have characters right okay I tell
me I'm gonna give you a full on other
Rogi because I like the idea of
depiction pal and especially this idea
of if these are all different universes
then one of them happens to look like a
universe or something so that we can
have some blade characters but also it's
not like by the way the Avengers never
noticed there were vampires here too I
think we have to explain that a little
more nuanced do you know me I'm all
about subtlety in nuance and I just hope
to have that from one division I got the
next theory so okay
my first part of the theory I introduced
to say I didn't introduce the idea but
maybe we're saying that we're gonna look
at the the multiverse in the MCU and
this is the MCS version of hey this is
what the multiverse looks like fans
what if Marvel is gonna get so freakin
aggressive with this and do like a Tommy
Westfall thing and say that every
different on-screen fictional universe
you've seen could plausibly exist within
the Marvel multiverse immortal cinematic
multiverse so that's why we're seeing
different sitcoms notice how they're
kind of doing like ABC own sitcoms like
Full House was
ABC Roseann was ABC they might start
saying like hey the different universes
that we own the license to are now
places that exist within the the
cinematic multiverse of Marvel what they
might start doing is in addition to New
Mutants why stop there why not have
Wanda visit a universe where Deadpool
and negasonic teenage warhead and
Colossus exist so that's how they
introduce how this could exist they
visit worlds where the old Fox x-men
existed including you know McAvoy
Charles Xavier what's-his-face as
magneto and we can see all that universe
as well and maybe we have like Hugh
Jackman coming for a cameo and this is
how they're able to say all the Disney
acquisitions exist within this
multiverse and maybe they'll even get
super aggressive and try to work Tom
Holland in there or just like a wink at
like spider-man existing and not just
spider-man like venom and carnage
Morbius Gwen Stacy Miles Morales like
all we're gonna see like little winks
maybe she just goes to a corner of like
Brooklyn and then there's some graffiti
drawn by Miles Morales just like Disney
we don't have to pay the rights to this
but like were we're coming for you Sony
with with all of our millions and
billions we're gonna buy you out at some
point and it's all going to be adopted
into our giant big one division is a
conduit
because she can visit you it means we
get to own you soon are you implying
then that there is going to be an
animated or a number of animated ones
yes you already nodding so then
specifically there's gonna be a universe
that is the cartoon show recess then
aired on ABC after-school yuck every
single one of these little ABC fires
yeah yeah she's gonna visit Tatooine and
run into mando and baby Yoda it's
basically going to be Patton Oswalt's
filibuster ran relaxin wreck come to
life super raghida
oh I just feel like if they can why not
if they can just hint at it and make
jokes about it like then let the
redditors go crazy and speculate where
this could what's the point of the mouse
owning everything if we can't jelica try
to follow that yeah so so with my theory
the the House of M reverse one right it
not only establishes mutants in them see
you but hear me out okay so in the
trailer it hops between different
sitcoms from different decades right so
we see the I Love Lucy looking scene
from the fifties the sixties looking
bewitched one well the x-men movies kind
of follow a similar decade pattern oh so
yeah we see first class in the sixties
you know I think yeah yeah and it keeps
going so what if while Wanda and vision
are going through each of these decades
you know in her consciousness and she's
resetting these realities so to speak
what if they see basically like each
mutant origin story
so like magneto you know in the 40s or
something like that set up Cyclops in a
different decade Wolverine in another
decade and until they reached you know
present-day MCU and they've basically
just set up all the mutants and they're
canonical you know existence and their
origins yeah yeah did these so why did
those mutants not exist before not
scenario so if this is be post sentence
you said yeah yeah because she's trying
to resurrect solution with these wishful
yeah wishful scenarios that she's
creating vision come back so she says
what while she's hopping through each
decade she's essentially setting up the
origin of each of these mutants and
there are it's almost like she's
creating x-men she's merging the web but
it's almost like a ripple effect that is
flowing through time kind of like the
Star Trek Nexus different time periods
and Star Trek in in the generations
all the different time periods are
getting affected by this wave that is
changing things so yeah that's that's
interesting people through time yeah in
this way it's great so the it's not like
she just wakes up one day and it's like
now there are mutants and then like we
don't know what their backstories are we
get to like remind everyone in the MCU
like how magneto came into this world
and and and how wolverine joined this so
like it feels like they were here the
whole time it's really important because
right this some of them their backstory
is what made the character right you
know Holocaust survivor now is kind of
like if it'd be strange if a brand new
character tried to have that backstory
but if he was there all along so yeah
what the I Love Lucy like black and
whites you know nice wholesome scene
that we saw in the trailer but they're
all knocks on the door or something yeah
there's a real dark episode of I Love
Lucy but like how much would you love to
see that and like you know Logan or
Wolverine just hop in and during like
the Brady Bunch 70s looking part of the
trailer and he's like playing pool in a
bars I'm thank you all right interesting
I really like the time travel element
you get a Rogi I'm feeling that give
them back to me in a tweet incorporate
your first theory again and then a tag
on to your tweet thread with the second
tweet okay so my first tweet was one
division introduces a Marvel multiverse
which includes every universe you know
second tweet include redacted including
every Disney owned property so far and
their soon-to-be acquisitions including
you Sony spider-verse 100% that which
who will travel to Disney Hell Wanda
Maximoff will answer that Bell saving
her beloved vision why that's a
no-brainer decision blade it's too late
to add the rhyme to this thread you had
a memed
to eat
then it started to rise its diverse
content wow yeah mixed I would have been
impressive you rhymed the meme roll the
tape back you'll see okay so I think it
was a reverse House of M House of Wanda
x-men throughout time oh that's mine
throughout time that's a very fun Super
Nintendo game
great uh no different rookies for that
route of tweets but I feel like okay of
everything you guys said I feel like
which is this kind of - normal 30% of
what you guys said might end up in this
show which shows you how freaking insane
this shows yeah what do you guys think
is the most likely of all this stuff is
gonna actually show up I think the
mutant one is the most likely because
that's a house of M is so tied to the
mutants story and I and I feel like
Angelica's on the money at least with
their first part and then I could see
maybe at least one of those instances in
the past like a wink to Logan or Charles
Xavier in there yeah yeah I agree
yeah alright so this is where we're
gonna really figure out who here is
going to take home the ultimate prize of
your ultimate wish coming true this is
going to be for all the roadies three
questions one this Sunday is the Oscars
and Joaquin Phoenix is nominated for
Best Actor for yo Kerr now give me your
best impression of Phoenix in characters
Yoker giving his acceptance speech you
know what's funny Catherine zeta-jones
you know it's funny this disturbed Big
Bang why am I getting shot stage not
that
ever since I was a little boy my mother
said I love to make people give me
awards when I played Little League
baseball I struck out every time I was
up to bat and they still gave me the
most valuable player awards because they
were scared of me thank you for this
award I want to thank my management at
CAA I want to thank my entertainment
lawyer Lawrence Smith Esquire I want to
thank my wife a rough-cut Angelica is it
just me or is it getting crazier out
there and then he just dances all all of
them equally creepy because you were
like giving sight eyes birds of prey
opens this weekend give me your best
impression of MA you didn't have a lot
of ideas this week huh off screen give
me your best impression of Margot Robbie
accepting her 2021 Oscar for Best
Actress in character as Harley Quinn
because remember they have to do it in
character giving me this award without
wrong because when I say wrong my
Australian accent comes in room
reference to a brief I want to thank the
Academy a lot of people know this was a
difficult year for me losing my husband
the Joker after I made the movie we were
very far apart
but we came back together and started to
heal and I begged him not to kill Batman
but he tried to and he fell into a vat
of acid and it made him look normal
again and that drove him crazy and then
he got in a dune buggy and rode out into
the desert where he still is missing and
presumed dead thank you for this award
and may God have mercy on all of our
souls you got a picture with the daddy's
little [ __ ] top the whole time that's I
always thought I picture you okay so she
she picture this she walks up onstage
he's chewing gum and she goes did anyone
see where that joacquin guy went and
then she gets her bat and she hits the
world she smashes it somehow Jojo what
Quinn is not that it's what I should
call for now jo koy she's hardly green
guys Vin Diesel has hinted that the
final Fast and Furious movie could be
broken up into two movies like Kill Bill
Oh like Kill Bill yeah so along those
lines
give me your best impression of Vin
Diesel accepting his 2023 Best Actor
Oscar for fast and furious 10-part to
the like pitch thought up like you know
oh you thought that was too low you
needed to be pitched up that's your
lowest you go come on are we picking
that up tell me what he got first thing
I want to thank my family cuz that's
what it's all about family I want to
thank Ludacris rule
Ryan Reynolds the other people in this
movie Kurt Russell Paul Walker's brother
with that weird CGI Asian people in this
movie I cannot remember the cars which I
consider family as well
the helicopters which I also consider my
family Corona which is the family drink
that we make everyone drink including
little Brian my son named after my
friend Brian who was an FBI agent and a
cop but it's now an illegal street racer
that Rob's things with me we got a real
problem in this world with over cooking
rice okay all right that's your time
Rice's worse
sounds like Jackson made this speech
but then he comes back who works the
hardest on that will tell me talk the
longest but Eric's covered in sound role
now and your parents are worried about
you they've been texting me all day
sorry guys so where did I leave our
point totals what that's the best you've
ever done yeah yeah for inflation though
that's two mm I have three Angelica we
we think you're cool you need a wish for
that we also all thought your theory was
the best okay yeah let's say Eric's wish
is that we recreate the opening title
sequence of Rosanna Eric's gonna explain
this okay so you know they're all
sitting at the table eating dinner and
then if the camera pivots 360 degrees so
we're gonna do that here okay and we're
gonna add I'm gonna send this video to
post we'll add like a license free
version of that Chicago blues music that
plays the Blues Traveler and we're gonna
do a 360 around the table just like they
do in the opening of Rosanna
[Music]
thanks so much we're going broke with us
thanks to our special guest Erik Bosse
yeah thanks for making time coming
although hey downstairs
Tommy's back told mr. earlobes are
squeezed and I'm like Tommy back
pleasure from release is a toxin it's
like LSD and Angelica trade thanks so
much for being back so sorry about what
Tommy did during the break you release
go everywhere again someone call my
lawyer guys make sure to follow this as
a podcast version so you can hear it
first and hear how disgusting it sounds
just audio version you can find it
anywhere that you get your podcast and
also make sure to follow the rockstars
in general just add new rock shows on
all the socials and you'll see when our
videos come out and whatnot and you
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Phillip Malina that's it for this
episode but I'm really curious what you
guys think it's actually gonna happen in
one division so make sure to tell us in
the comments and we'll shout some out in
the future episode thanks
[Music]